in our eye on America America left
behind series were shining a spotlight
on the hidden world of the working
homeless members of the working class
who spend their days at work and their
nights living in their vehicles with a
permanent solution seemingly out of
reach CBS News contributor Maria Elena
Salinas is here with more good morning
Maria
good morning Michelle now earning a
regular paycheck used to also give
Americans a chance to pay for a place to
live but the cost of housing especially
in major US cities has been skyrocketing
it's left many families desperate and
just a warning
one father's desperation and where it
led him could be disturbing for younger
viewers actually all viewers Aaron Steve
begins in darkness you do what you need
to do to get through a given day you get
rest when you can today he's facing a
cold rain and a two-hour commute by
scooter and bus to his job at the post
office you just keep going through the
process of trying to get into better
circumstances
and when he's done this is home he's
right here
resting he just came in Aaron his wife
Celia and their two children have lived
in this parking lot outside of Seattle
for the past nine months when he has a
day off he will be in the front seat and
then the guinea pigs are at our feet
these guinea pigs are therapy for their
son Daniel was autistic and traumatized
by the family situation before we got
the guinea pigs he was not very verbal
he didn't speak a lot it was very hard
on Daniel he and I were out here
he said I hate this life and I hate you
they asked us daily when will we get a
house when will we get a partner how
long are we gonna stay here and always
we don't know we are trying our best
because we are trying of us but their
best never seems to be good enough in
part because Aaron makes $17 an hour
often too much money to qualify for
public housing assistance I reached a
point where I really didn't see any hope
for our situation that sense of
hopelessness led Aaron to contemplate
suicide as a way to give his family a
better life I looked up what my likely
Social Security death benefits for my
children would be silly and the kids
were asleep and I tried to hang myself
and the belt didn't hold
I
a few spaces away Chrissie her husband
and their three children are also trying
to hold on to their dignity they've been
living in their vehicles for six months
what is the biggest challenge in trying
to secure housing for you and your kids
the lack thereof so we have to settle
for whatever housing they give us and
they don't have much housing to give
both families live here at the Lake
Washington United Methodist Church
parking lot
Karina O'Malley is a director of the
church's safe parking program it's a
secure location with bathrooms in the
kitchen and access to social services
there are so many situations that would
lead someone to end up living in their
car have you noticed a pattern of any
kind the main reason that people end up
in their cars is because income does not
match housing cost a family with
children that makes $17 an hour they
can't afford to rent what do they do
it's exactly right it's why we need more
affordable housing Gini Durkin is the
mayor of Seattle where the median income
needed to afford a two-bedroom apartment
is more than $75,000 a year it's getting
more and more difficult for people in
the middle class to live in Seattle
we need to have a decade of housing
where we actually build enough housing
for the people living in this region
that's not soon enough for Aaron all
right thank you very much he and Celia
were denied an apartment a rejection
that has now happened 10 times in his
last application Aaron was over the
threshold to be eligible okay after
waiting it the news was better for their
neighbors who see in Matthew apartment
application was accepted for the first
time in more than a year they'll have a
roof over their heads and a place to
call home
just gonna wake up in my truck tomorrow
come nightfall Aaron will set out again
into the darkness hoping hard work
perseverance and a little help will
provide his family with a brighter
future I love them more than anything or
anyone else
and it's an issue not just in Seattle
but across the country housing so
heartbreaking you you feel at least they
have a safe parking lot but that
shouldn't be not you are working you are
earning nineteen dollars an hour to not
be able to find housing we've got to fix
this we talked about the minimum wage
crisis there's that crisis of affordable
housing no matter what city right and
here in Seattle the issue is safe
parking and not enough safe parking this
is one that's outside of the city of
Seattle and King County I think maybe
there's two or three like that but you
have thousands of people living in their
vehicles where they can't find a place
to park because they have to constantly
be moving and everything that that comes
with that right with the complexity
especially if you have kids of living in
out of your car now did the math a
monthly rent
$6,200 I can't believe it it's very very
sad and it and you were right saying
this is not something that happens to me
in Seattle it's across the country
unfortunately and you know the woman we
interview there really got it right in
the problem is you know the disparity
between the whole the salaries and the
price of housing right thank you very
much thank you so much